we nee divided 0.25 into one point zero
three zero seven five now the first
thing you want to do when your devise or
the number that you're dividing into the
other number is a decimal is to multiply
it by ten enough times so that it
becomes a whole number so you can shift
the decimal to the right so every time
you multiply something by ten you're
shifting the decimal over to the right
once so in this case we want to shift it
over to the right once and twice 0.25
times ten twice is the same thing as
0.25 times 100 and we'll turn the point
two five into 25 now if you do that with
the devise or you also have to do that
with the dividend the number that you're
dividing into so we also have to
multiply this by 10 twice or another way
of viewing it is shift the decimal over
to the right twice so we shift it over
once twice it will sit right over here
and to see why that makes sense you just
have to realize that this expression
right here this division problem is the
exact same thing as having 0.25 is the
exact same thing let me make it is the
exact same thing as having one point
zero three zero seven five divided by
divided by 0.25 and so we're multiplying
the 0.25 by 10 twice we're essentially
multiplying it by 100 let me do that in
a different color we're multiplying it
by a hundred in the denominator this is
the divisor or we're multiplying it by
100 so we also have to do the same thing
to the numerator if we don't want to
change this expression we don't change
the number so we also have to multiply
that by 100 and when you do that this
becomes 25 and this becomes a hundred
and three point zero seven five now let
me just rewrite this sometimes if you're
doing this in a workbook or something
you don't have to rewrite as long as you
remember where the decimal is but I'm
going to rewrite it just so it's a
little bit neater so we multiplied both
the divisor and the dividend by a
hundred this problem becomes 25 25
divided into divided into 100
three point zero seven five these are
going to result in the exact same
quotient they're the exact same fraction
if you want to view it that way we've
just multiplied both the numerator and
the denominator by a hundred to shift
the decimal over to the right twice now
that we've done that we're ready to
divide so the first thing we have 25
here and there's always a little bit of
an art to dividing something by a
multiple digit number so we'll see how
well we can do so 25 does not go into
125 does not go into 10 25 does go into
103 we know that 4 times 25 is 100 so 25
goes into 100 3 4 times 4 times 5 is 20
4 times 2 is 8 plus 2 is 100 we knew
that 4 times 4 quarters is a dollar it's
a hundred cents and now we subtract 100
3 minus 100 is going to be 3 and now we
can bring down we can bring down this 0
so we bring down that zero there 25 goes
into 30 one time and if we want we can
immediately put this decimal here we
don't have to wait until the end of the
problem this decimal sits right in that
place so we could always have that
decimal sitting right there in our
quotient or in our answer or our
quotient so anyway we were at 25 goes
into 30 one time one times 25
one times 25 is 25 and then we can
subtract 30 minus 25 well that's just 5
I'm going to do all of this borrowing
business or regrouping this can become a
10 this becomes a 2 10 minus 5 is 5
2 minus 2 is nothing but anyway 30 minus
25 is 5 now we bring down now we can
bring down this 7 25 goes into 57 2
times right 25 times 2 is 50 25 goes
into 57 2 times 2 times 25 is 50 and now
we subtract again 57 minus 50 is 7 and
now we're almost done we can bring down
this 5 we bring down that 5 right over
there
there 25 goes into 75 3 times 3 times 3
times 25 is 75 we say 3 times 5 is 15
regroup the 1 we can ignore that that
was from before 3 times 2 is 6 plus 1 is
7 so you can see that and then we
subtract and then we have we have no
remainder so 25 goes into 100 3.07 5
exactly 4 point 1 2 3 times which makes
sense because 25 goes into 100 about 4
times this is a little bit larger than
100 it's going to be a little bit more
than 4 times and that's going to be the
exact same answer as the number of times
that 0.25 goes into 1 point 0 3 0 7 5
this will also be this will also be 4
point 1 2 3 so this fraction or this
expression is the exact same thing as 4
point 1 2 3 and we're done